what we're going to do in this video is
a little bit of a deep dive on
transcription and just as a bit of a
review we touch on it on the video on on
replication transcription and
translation transcription in everyday
language just means to rewrite something
or to rewrite some information in
another form and that's essentially
what's happening here transcription is
when we take the information encoded in
a gene in DNA and encode essentially
that same information at in mRNA so
transcription we are going from DNA we
are going from DNA to messenger
messenger RNA and we're going to in this
video focus on genes that code for
proteins so this first step is the
transcription the DNA to messenger RNA
and then in a future video we'll dig a
little bit deeper into translation we
will translate that information into
into an actual protein but these
diagrams give a little bit of an
overview of it it's a little bit simpler
and bacteria you have the DNA just
floating around in the cytosol and so
the transcription takes place you you
start with that DNA that protein coding
gene and that in the DNA and then from
that you code the messenger RNA you see
that in that purple color right over
here and then that messenger RNA can be
involved with the ribosome and that's
the translation process to actually
produce the polypeptide to produce the
protein in eukaryotic cells and we're
going to get into a little bit more
depth in this video the transcription
the DNA to mRNA that happens inside of
the nucleus and there's essentially two
steps here you go from DNA to what we
would call pre mRNA let me write that
down
pre mRNA which would be which is
depicted right over there
and then it needs to be processed to
turn into what we would call mRNA which
then can leave the nucleus to be
translated into a protein so now that we
have that overview let's dig a little
bit deeper into this and understand the
different actors and understand if we're
talking about a eukaryotic cell what
type of processing might actually go
on so right over here we are going to
start with the protein coding gene
inside of the DNA right over here and we
are going to the primary actor that's
not the DNA or the mRNA here is going to
be RNA polymerase it's used to create a
sequence that will become a nucleotide
sequence that will become the messenger
RNA so this RNA polymerase it needs to
know where to start and the way it knows
where to start is it attaches to a
sequence of the DNA known as a promoter
and every gene is going to have a
promoter associated with it especially
if we're talking about eukaryotic cells
sometimes you might have a promoter
associated with a collection of genes as
well but in general if you've got a gene
you're going to have a promoter and so
that's where the part that's how the RNA
polymerase knows to attach right over
there and so once it attaches well then
it is able to separate the strands it
separates the strands and it's pretty
interesting because when we go too deep
into replication you saw all of these
actors the helicase and whatever else
but this RNA polymerase complex is
actually quite capable not only it
separates the strand and then it's
actually able to code for the RNA and it
does that the same way that when we
study DNA polymerase it does it in only
one direction it can only add more
nucleotides on the 3-prime end so it
encodes from the five prime to the three
prime direction notice this arrow here
we're extending it on the three prime
end of the RNA and so as you can see
here when it does this it's only it's
only encoding one side of or it's only
interacting I guess you could say or
coding complementary information to one
side but let's think about this a little
bit we could call the side that it is
that is that is forming that it is
interacting with you call that the
template strand because that's forming
that's acting that side of the DNA is
acting as the template for forming that
RNA but if you think about the
information that that RNA is actually
going to encode well it's going to its
contain the same information as the
coding strand of DNA is the other strand
of DNA because these include these
nucleotides right over here this
nucleotide is going to be complementary
to this one over here just as this come
this nucleotide was complementary to
that one over there and you can see it a
little bit more depth if we actually
were to add the nucleotides so this is
the template strand if you have a
thymine well on the are the RNA you
would have the adenine and look on the
coding strand of DNA the one up here you
would also have an adenine and they are
essentially the coding strand and the
RNA essentially ends up being the same
sequence with the one difference is that
you won't find the thymine in the RNA
instead you will find a similar you'll
find a a similar nitrogenous base and
that is your cell but your cell plays
the role of thymine so you're
essentially coding the same information
so once again this bottom strand is
acting as a template but it's going to
be the resulting RNA that gets coded is
essentially going to have the same
information that we had in the coding
strand and just to get an appreciation
for what this looks like and I would
even write you know put looks in
quotations I even do the quote things
with my fingers when I said that is that
you know it's hard to really visualize
what these things look like but you can
see here that the RNA polymerase complex
and this is for a specific organism can
be very very complex and involved and
it's fascinating how these things
interact and every time you're studying
biology and someone like me is going to
give you these nice clean narratives of
how the these these enzymes interact
with the different macromolecules like
the DNA or the RNA should always
remember it this is amazing this these
are these molecules interacting with
each other bouncing into each other it's
happening incredibly fast inside of the
cell you should be in awe of this it's
it's happening in in in in all of your
cells or as we as we speak so this is
this is pretty incredible stuff so the
next thing you have to want to think
about you know this right over here we
are extending the RNA well what does
this thing actually stop and it stops
once once we so this this RNA polymerase
is going to keep going on and then
is blue where we we've labeled this a
terminator so let me right so this area
is a terminator and there's multiple
ways that that signals to the RNA
polymerase that hey it's it's time to
stop or and more particularly that it
somehow creates something structurally
that the the polymerase just let's go
one mechanism that's depicted right over
here is that the the the mRNA that's
coated and this is typical at this or
this can happen in bacteria is that the
mRNA that's coded forms a hairpin so it
has to have the right complementary base
pairs base pairs right over here to form
this hairpin
but there's hairpin along with the
things around the hairpin essentially
make it impair the the polymerase to
keep on going and so the complex kind of
changes a little bit and so it lets go
or at least that's how people believe it
there's other forms of how the
Terminator can act it might be sequences
that parts of the polymerase complex
recognize and it forms it makes a
conformation change so that the RNA
polymerase let's go now if we're talking
about a if we're talking about a
prokaryote we're done we would have
formed this will be our messenger RNA
which then can go to a ribosome and then
be translated into a protein but if
we're talking about a eukaryote well
then we have to do a little bit of
processing if we're talk about a
eukaryote if this is a prokaryote right
over here this would be our mRNA if this
is a eukaryote then this is our pre mRNA
which now has to be processed and you
might say well how is that going to be
processed well there's a couple of
things that are going to be done some
things are going to be added at the
beginning and the end of the mRNA
the five prime cap this is a modified
guanine modified modified guanine right
over here which is going to help in the
translation process as the ribosomes
attached on to it and then you have this
poly a tail and it's called a poly a
tail because it has a bunch of ad means
at the end right over here and these not
only help
in the translation process it helps it
helps make sure that the information is
more robust at the ends of the MRNA
don't in some way become or makes it
less likely that they're going to become
damaged now the other thing that needs
to be processed and this is one of those
fascinating things in evolutionary
biology is that we will have in this M&R
in this mRNA sequence you're going to
have parts of the sequence which we
currently consider to be nonsense
sequence nonsense sequences and we call
them introns and I'm going to put it in
quotes because in general and evolution
it's it's seldom that things have
absolutely no purpose but these are not
coding for the protein that is going to
be coded by our initial gene and so
these are actually processed out they
are spliced out and I'm not going to go
into all the details of the actors that
cause the splicing but as part of this
eukaryotic processing you add the you
add the cap you add the tail and then
you splice out the introns and then once
you've spliced out the introns all you
have left are the exons so you have that
is going to be connected to that it's
going to be connected to that and so
this is what you have resulted this is
in a you carry out your mRNA and that's
what we saw that's what we saw right
over here that can then let me underline
that in a color you can see right over
here which then migrates out of the
nucleus to a ribosome where it can be
translated